après examen hier autour du producteur
de cannabis can trust d'annoncer des
mises à pied
l'entreprise ontarienne va supprimer
jusqu'à 140 emplois soit le quart de son
personnel d'ici la fin de l'année
cannes 3 espère ainsi épargnés jusqu'à
400 mille dollars par mois
entrust est en gestion de crise depuis
juillet lorsque santé canada a découvert
des irrégularités dans ses usines qui
ont entraîné la suspension de sa licence
de production
le pdg de l'entreprise et le président
du conseil d'administration ont été
remerciés et 180 employés avaient déjà
été mis à pied en septembre
l'action de cannes cross qui était à
plus de 13 dollars en mars dernier vont
maintenant moins de 2 dollars avec nous
il n'y a ni cléroux un conseiller chez
me disent yannick l'hérault un bon soir
soit gérald un an après la légalisation
du cannabis là les entreprises on voit
des entreprises comme s'occuper des
emplois supprimé des emplois qu'est ce
qui ne va pas présentement un dur
lendemain de veille après l'euphorie a
mais c'est la réalité économique qui
s'affirme gérald il y avait au départ
des projections financières qui étaient
très optimistes on voulait vendre un
nouveau secteur naissant au potentiel
immense
or aujourd'hui ce qu'on s'aperçoit ce
sont des problèmes associés à la
croissance d'un secteur
oui qui a peut-être un potentiel très
prometteur mais qui en est encore à ses
balbutiements donc des problèmes
d'exécution des problèmes de gestion de
capital et surtout la rampe la
rentabilité de ces entreprises là on
n'est pas encore au rendez vous et nous
chemise si nous n'investissons pas dans
les entreprises qui sont déficitaires et
malheureusement c'est une des
caractéristiques pour ces entreprises là
on sait pas quand elles vont devenir
rentable de son pressing
est ce qu'un ange et de compétences chez
les dirigeants en ce moment ben un des
problèmes qui tu as aussi haut à
l'entrée en bourse
des entreprises qui ont un faible
historique et c'est le peu de
connaissances que l'on note des
dirigeants et visiblement c'est ce que
l'on voit en ce moment on ne connaissait
pas les dirigeants leurs compétences et
on voit qu'ils aient des problèmes
d'exécution
on voit également que les dirigeants ont
vendu des attentes très élevées ont fait
des promesses importantes aux
investisseurs pour avoir une
valorisation très généreuse en bourse
et quand il ya des ratés ce qui peut
être normal dans un secteur naissant et
bien les attentes se dégonfle et ça fait
en sorte que les prix des actions en
bourse diminue en conséquence alors la
chute est quand même importante on va
regarder quelques entreprises par
exemple depuis le 17 octobre 2018 depuis
le jour de la légalisation du cannabis à
des fins récréatives cannes 3 a perdu 87
% pour toutes sortes de problèmes
différents aussi on en parlait aurora
cannabis 61%
exo 60% l'entreprise québécoise et
canopy notamment 56% donc d'aider des
entreprises sont en baisse et là des
suppressions d'emplois des révisions à
la baisse de résultat financier exo qui
retire aussi ses résultats ses
prévisions pour 2020
on a mal prévu la croissance du secteur
en quelque sorte
il faut dire gerald qu'il y a plein
d'impondérables qui sont à la fois des
problèmes internes louis des entreprises
mais aussi des éléments qui sont hors de
contrôle des dirigeants de ces
entreprises là ne serait ce que le fait
que c'est un marché qui est contrôlé par
les gouvernements et en plus la
distribution dans bien des juridictions
elle est contrôlé également par les
gouvernements donc par exemple si pour
une raison ou pour une autre
une province décide de ralentir la
cadence des ouvertures
deux magasins où l'on distribue le
cannabis c'est bien ça va faire en sorte
que les projections financières qu'on
avait établi au départ ne tienne tout
simplement plus et je voyais aujourd'hui
aussi que les analystes ne s'entendent
même pas sur le potentiel et le
potentiel de rentabilité des grands
producteurs de cannabis qui sont livrés
gagnant quand on voit l'action b c comme
ceux ci qui a fait de l'argent et qui en
perd une excellente question générale
des évaluations ont été gonflés par la
spéculation en syrie si on remonte avant
la légalisation il y à un peu plus d'un
an
on voyait des valeurs qui était accordée
à ces entreprises là qui était
complètement démentiel si vous me
permettez l'expression
on voyait par exemple canopée grog qui
est tu as vu comme un des chefs de file
du secteur qui avaient une évaluation
supérieure à la valeur accordée à des
entreprises bien établies combiné par
exemple de mawson et d'autres géants de
la distribution produits alimentaires du
canada
donc ça s'était basé sur des des
prévisions très optimistes alors ce
qu'on voit c'est que ses prévisions lors
se dégonfle et malheureusement dans les
petits investisseurs qui ont évalué le
potentiel très prometteur de ce secteur
là vont se retrouver parmi les grands
perdants parce que souvent on y va lui
paul le risque associé à ces placements
est ce qu'on parle ça ressemble à une
but du cannabis ou cd ajustements
normaux pour une pour une industrie qui
est naissant sur le plan légal on peut
dire que ce sont des ajustements qui
sont très normaux quand on considère que
les valeurs accordé au secteur l'année
dernière était insoutenable
considérant les projections financières
qui avaient été émises le litre set
était extrêmement cher donc les
déceptions qui se succèdent depuis
quelques mois font en sorte que les
valeurs
accorder aux entreprises s'ajuste à des
prévisions qui vont être plus réaliste
parce que nous sommes en général on ne
sait pas quand ces entreprises là vont
être rentable certains parlent de 2009
21 mais ça peut aller au delà
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
plusieurs de ces entreprises là pourrait
manquer de liquidités dans les prochains
mois si jamais elle n'arrive pas à
obtenir davantage de capital des
investisseurs intéressant on va
surveiller cela de près il y en écriront
et merci ça me fait plaisir